this is lignite one of the dirtiest
forms of coal mined from a 50 square
kilometer hole that has swallowed dozens
of villages and threatens another six in
the coming years the garzweiler mine
providing power to the western most
industrialized part of germany lies in
the same state where deadly floods
struck last july a result of extreme
rainfall attributed to global warming
i can't understand why germany continues
this policy they say we will stop in
2038 but that is too late it is
unthinkable that in 2027 villages will
have to disappear to mine coal that
damages the climate marital's family has
been living in kukum for generations a
nearly abandoned village now since many
residents have left due to plans to
demolish their houses rwe the energy
company is expanding the mine because
according to the coal exit strategy it
can extract lignite for 17 more
years the
merkel has signed the paris agreement
but here we see that the climate goals
are undermined the mine should stop
where it is now otherwise germany does
not stay within the goal of 1.5 degrees
temperature rise
while germany can rely more on renewable
energy than other european countries
fossil fuels have recently made a
comeback to prevent blackouts due to a
shortage of wind and solar energy to put
pressure on politicians to speed up the
energy transition climate activists have
set up camp in a village that is about
to be demolished by the mining company
these mines have become a symbol for
germany's struggle to move away from
fossil fuels to some it shows that
angela merkel should have done more to
deserve her title as climate chancellor
but to others this transition to green
energy is going way too fast
a nostalgic sound for former coal miners
like jurgen jakubelt who spent 33 years
working underground until the last deep
coal mine closed in 2018.
it was the end of an industry that
provided work for half a million people
in the 1950s and helped to rebuild
germany after world war ii yakubelt who
now guides tourists thinks the industry
he helped build close too soon what kind
of cooler we don't want coal we don't
want lignite we don't want nuclear
energy and with new forms of energy we
can't generate enough power for our
economy so what are we doing now we are
importing coal climate chancellor or not
angela merkel leaves a mixed legacy
looking at our policies to reduce
emissions analysts say the next
chancellor has no choice but to speed up
the energy transition and try to fill
merkel's large shoes internationally
angela merkel's start was also a modest
start so she emerged as a great leader
over time and the only thing what we can
hope is that the future chancellor
whoever it be the future chancellor
is also a leader which will be respected
germans vote on sunday which direction
they want the country and its energy
transition to go but many agree the
train moving away from the traditional
coal industry has become unstoppable
staff farsen al jazeera recklinghausen